a new anti-woke Hero has surfaced for
many on the anti-trans right his name is
Senator Matt McKee he is a state senator
in Arkansas he did the heroic thing
where he asked a trans pharmacist
whether she has a penis and this makes
you a hero among much of the anti-trans
right let me set this up for you uh
before we play the clip and the clip is
quite stunning Arkansas has been on this
Warpath to do things that really aren't
worth doing in order to Virtue signal
like for example Arkansas governor Sarah
Huckabee Sanders signing a law Banning
critical race Theory being taught in
public schools which of course it's not
being taught in public schools so it
doesn't really matter okay Arkansas also
is on this path to criminalize gender
affirming Care Medical Care we're
talking about and this is part of the
battle against trans people and there
was an almost surreal moment
during which Republican state senator
Matt McKee asked a trans pharmacist
Gwendolyn Herzig whether she has a penis
now the bill that was being discussed
eventually passed on Monday morning with
only one Democrat at the meeting voting
against it this is Senate Bill 199 to
open up doctors who provide gender
affirming care to youth
significant uh loopholes and additional
malpractice liabilities and all sorts of
different things in order to make it
more difficult to provide that care and
so a pharmacist named Wendell and Herzig
who is a trans-arkansas
spoke against the bill spoke against SB
199 shared her experience as a trans
person and health care provider in the
state of Arkansas she did not receive
much respect but she was asked do you
have a penis take a listen to this you
said that you're a trans woman I trans
female yes sir do you have a penis
that's horrible you're the one you're
the one that brought that into the
discussion yeah really on the Vanguard
of political philosophy and medical
treatment as you can see here do you
have a penis I would turn it around on
this guy and say sir I know you're a
dick but do you have a penis
um the obsession with other people's
genitalia
is really something the anti-trans
people consider that heroic they think
that's a massive anti-woke Victory to
really ask the questions that need
asking it's biology and Truth or
whatever it is right globalist
International yeah you know this stuff I
hate to say it folks I really do
I would get out of Arkansas and the
reason I hate to say it is most people
can't just easily move to another state
that it's just a reality either for
financial reasons because you're
established in a certain State your
job's not mobile your family is not
mobile everyone you know is in a
particular place so you know my instinct
is always to say
work within the system and figure out
how to improve things and Lobby and all
these different things Arkansas is
becoming so backwards we've looked at
the health care numbers near the bottom
we've looked at the crime numbers near
the worst in the country we've looked at
the education numbers we've looked at
the infrastructure numbers Arkansas is
not a great place to be and I'm sure
Little Rock has beautiful cafes and you
can get a great cappuccino and maybe
even a bagel but
um it it's really going in a bad
Direction now under the stewardship if
you can call it that of Sarah Huckabee
Sanders wasting resources and money and
time on meaningless things the openly
anti-trans attacks that are going on I
don't know at this point that it's the
sort of thing where listen if you don't
if if you don't have
if you're in the position to say I can
deal with a horrible place for 10 years
because I want to make it better through
activism I'm with you I'm with you but
for so many people at this point
it has become so disastrous in that
state
that it may be time to leave and that's
a really difficult thing to do in a lot
of different ways but it has gotten
disastrously bad in Arkansas do you have
a penis the latest in the battle lines
against the wokesters or whatever it is
they call it they see this as a victory
we see it as humiliating
um a lying Republican now says that when
you call out her lies you're being
anti-hispanic this is exactly the
nonsense that the right accuses the left
of doing I will remind you that there is
this new Republican congresswoman Anna
Paulina Luna she lied about being Jewish
we talked about it yesterday she's not
actually Jewish she has since been
called out for her lies she says to
Charlie Kirk during an appearance
yesterday that when her lies are called
out it is anti-hispanic that's an
interesting perspective let's listen and
to say that I would make something like
that up why would they say that it's
because they don't want young Hispanics
to be reputable and if you look at the
slant of the entire article they say
that I'm not Hispanic enough even though
they cite where my grandparents
immigrated from but you know a lot of
what they do it's character
assassination and if you don't have
spine for it you can fold but I think
that we launched a full frontal assault
and we'll look forward to more
attraction soon yeah
um despite the claims of Republicans it
is actually Republicans who regularly
play the victim card this is another
example of accusations or confessions
this is another example of projection
this is another example of the right
developing a narrative about the left
that applies more to them than it does
to the left Republicans often claim
that the left always are victims we're
victims of racism say the leftists were
victims of xenophobia were victims of
sexism the leftists they want to be
victims but when you actually look
you see that Republicans have been
playing the victims for a long time now
the war on Christmas the Christians were
being victimized the war on religion the
claims aren't backed by evidence they
use them to Rally their base they use
them to raise money they use them to
purport to be the victims of some
liberal agenda oh the if you're straight
you're now being attacked just for being
straight another example they say we're
victims of election fraud there's no
evidence to support that and in fact
when individual perpetrators of
so-called election fraud are found they
are almost always Republicans either
trying to test the system or simply
trying to vote multiple times they say
the left does it they're they're the
ones getting caught doing it okay they
said an entire election was stolen from
them Trump's new thing uh no nobody's
been treated more unfairly than my
family all my friends do you have
friends sir all my friends tell me
nobody's been treated as unfairly as you
have but the left they're the ones who
play the victim and then of course they
often claim to be the victims of
discrimination or sometimes they'd like
to use the term reverse discrimination
or Reverse Racism or whatever the case
may be and yet when you actually look at
studies you find that it is people of
color communities of color marginalized
groups who are more likely to actually
be discriminated against and so by
claiming to be the victims of
discrimination they act they deny the
experiences of people who are actually
the victims of discrimination they
distract from real issues and of course
they become that which they criticize
the left for being and this is yet
another example they're going after me
for being Hispanic no they're going
going after you for being a liar
that's what this is at the end of the
day and so I don't really know the best
strategy for the left on this because if
you're on the left and you identify an
injustice you've gone woke you're
playing the victim card whatever
but then when they do it themselves and
we call it out because the right doesn't
care about hypocrisy anymore if they
ever did and because the right has
abandoned policy their voters don't
actually care they fall for yeah they're
going after Anna Paulina Luna because
she's a proud conservative Hispanic
woman no they're going after her because
she's a liar and she deserves it quite
simply Marjorie Taylor green used the
death count from the hijacked 911 Flight
93 to minimize the risk of shooting down
the Chinese spy balloon over land and
The Crowd Goes completely silent you
have to see this this is stunning
stunning stuff Marjorie Taylor green and
a bunch of right-wingers initially went
after Joe Biden by saying he's not going
to have the testicular fortitude that's
my word not theirs to shoot down the
Chinese surveillance balloon
As We Know Joe Biden eventually shot
down the Chinese surveillance balloon
and so Republicans had to shift their
tone shift their message some of them
shifted to who cares any president would
have done it but Marjorie Taylor green
is Shifting to he didn't need to wait
for the balloon to go over water before
shooting it down that was a move
he should have shot it down over land
and as proof as to how benign that is
think back to 9 11. remember when there
was that crash I mean even describing it
as a crash when there was that crash
nobody I mean yes everybody on the plane
died but nobody on the ground died it is
so quiet as Marjorie Taylor green says
these disgusting things in this room the
crowd was all jazzed up up until this
point it goes so quiet that if somebody
dropped a pin you would be able to hear
it take a look at this and then finally
leaves the coast and then oh they shot
it down
the excuses that were given on this were
pathetic absolutely pathetic they told
us it was too risky oh it was too risky
to shoot down the Chinese Bible and do
you know what a bunch of bullets that is
they said it's three school buses three
school buses wide okay well do you guys
remember on 9 11 when an airplane
crashed in Pennsylvania
a jetliner remember that oof it didn't
kill anybody on the ground killed
everyone on board but it didn't kill
silence instantly silenced anyone on the
ground so they want to tell all of us
that it was too risky to take down that
Chinese spindle in over rural Idaho or
Montana or any of these other states or
Alaska anyway quite a bold analogy to be
making but in the service of attacking
any decision made by Joe Biden anything
is fair game for people like Marjorie
Taylor green a disgusting person
usually I say a disgusting woman and
someone wrote to me and said David sir
might you be a misogynist because if a
man does something disgusting you say
what a disgusting person
but when Marjorie Taylor green does
something disgusting you say what a
disgusting woman
I don't know should I say disgusting
person she's definitely both as far as
we all know she's a woman uh in the in
the in the Valiant battle against trans
Focus Marjorie Taylor green has drawn
that Line in the Sand she is a woman
should I say she's a disgusting person
or a disgusting woman let me know but
disgusting certainly fits the bill
absolutely no tragedy she is unwilling
to use to her perceived Advantage we
will have all of these clips on our
YouTube channel youtube.com the
davidpackman show and we will also have
these clips in Spanish now on the
Spanish YouTube channel
youtube.com slash at symbol
David packman
espanol I know you're it's like isn't it
espanol but you can't in a URL have the
thing over the end so it's David Pacman
espanol for the Spanish channel it's
crazy I know but check it out
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
I invite you to become a supporter of
the David packman show by signing up at
joinpakman.com it's cheap it's quick
it's easy and it really is the number
one funding source for our program and
also your memberships now funding the
Spanish dubbed YouTube channel we got
our first Spanish hate mail just hours
after the channel went live uh you can I
posted actually to my Twitter
um the Spanish hate mail we got calling
me a communist and telling me I have bad
blood and all these different things so
it's going swimmingly I would say
already making an impact but in all
seriousness the membership program does
support all of the work we do you can
sign up at joinpakman.com read about the
great member benefits including the
world famous award-winning bonus show we
give the awards but still it's like we
did win some awards for the bonus show
you can use the coupon code 24 starts
now to get a discount and Boyd is 24
start now Trump has a channel Challenger
Nikki Haley but we'll get to that a
little bit later let's follow up first
about the UFOs the United States has now
officially said we do not believe that
the recent surveillance balloons slash
devices tentatively believed to be from
China are evidence of intelligent aliens
from another planet solar system or
Galaxy even visiting us on Earth uh Joe
Biden's press secretary Kareem
Jean-Pierre making that statement during
a press briefing yesterday we addressed
this from the White House I know there
have been questions and and concerns
about this but there is no again no
indication of aliens or extraterrestrial
activity with these recent takedowns
again there is no indication of aliens
or terrestrial activities it's funny
because the Press Corps laughs
but just look online there are endless
gobs of people
convinced that this is a cover-up of
extraterrestrial encounters everybody
with these recent takedowns wanted to
make sure that the American people knew
that all of you knew that and it was
important for us to say that from here
because we've been sure Karine that's
just what you would say if you wanted to
cover it up hearing a lot about it
um
I'm just you know I loved E.T the movie
but I'm just gonna leave it there all
right then National Security council's
John Kirby also reiterated this and said
this is these are not aliens it's not
aliens folks the top officials of the
Pentagon when asked explicitly if they
were ruling out any kind of
extraterrestrial presence said they
weren't ruling anything out and yet at
the beginning of today's briefing albeit
with her usual winning smile uh Ms
Jean-Pierre seemed to rule out any
extraterrestrial activity I don't think
the American people need to worry about
aliens with respect to these craft
period I don't think there's any now
you heard what he said right I don't
think the American people need to worry
about aliens
with respect to these craft and there
are those who believe that Kirby
is very narrowly answering this question
and saying these are not
extraterrestrial aliens but that doesn't
mean that there aren't others now let's
talk a little bit about aliens this is
this is a very interesting topic I want
to expand on what I said during my
recent appearance with Anthony pompliano
when I was down in Florida one of the
appearances I did was with Anthony
pompliano and he asked me about aliens
it is really important to understand the
sheer vastness of the universe you've
got our galaxy The Milky Way hundreds of
billions of stars and then all of the
accompanying planets and so on and so
forth so I do have a very general view
that based on what we know about the
vastness of the universe
statistically I think the likelihood of
extraterrestrial life of some kind could
be bacterial could be intelligence I
don't know
I think the odds are high the
probability of that intelligent life
having already visited Earth I believe
is extraordinarily low and and the sort
of math of it is as follows you look at
the number of stars in the universe it's
astronomical 100 billion in our you know
own Milky Way alone with that number of
stars it is likely that at least some
planets would be capable of supporting
life so the conditions at least
theoretically for life are probably not
that rare if you look at all of the
planets that there are you then say okay
well on some fraction of those that
could support life
it doesn't seem super unlikely even if
it's a small percentage that life would
develop and so I do think that when you
consider all of that and the age of the
universe 13.8 billion years old that's a
lot of time for life to have evolved on
other planets as well
so I think it is likely given the laws
of physics and chemistry which appear to
be Universal and all these different
things it's likely that there is life on
other planets do I think it has reached
Earth in the form of a balloon or a
cylinder or you know humanoid four foot
tall aliens with obsessed with anal
probes uh it must be proctology must be
big on other planets I don't know that I
don't have any evidence for and then
when you look at you know the the
numerous so-called UFO sightings over
the years we have a lack of concrete
evidence we see that the stories that
are told match the images of supposed
aliens from movies and from popular
culture and many are specifically
debunked as aircraft or weather balloon
or birds or whatever so you know there's
that there's the lack of physical
evidence and all of these different
things so really funny Coda to this
which is Mark esper Trump's former uh
Secretary of Defense who says you know
if aliens were to come here I don't
think this is exactly what they would do
careful
aliens would travel across the universe
and all of a sudden the
surveillance over Lake Huron in a
balloon moving 20 miles per hour that's
a plan that I think we're in good shape
and we now know we can shoot him down
but I I don't think that's true at all
look my hunch is that that these are
weather balloons or scientific
experiments put them off by another
country another com a company or some
non-profit we'll learn that in due
course yeah uh you know I I it makes
sense esper is not a guy that I found uh
super interesting as an elected official
or whatever but I do think this is a
good point and it's similar to you know
if if the aliens really were making
contact I don't know that their priority
would necessarily be anal probes and so
it's sort of weird that that's a big
part of a lot of the stories that are
told I think esper is right
but maybe that's just what the aliens
want us to think it's not us because we
would never just go 20 miles an hour
over one of the Great Lakes let me know
what you think I agree with Karine
Jean-Pierre and Kirby and esper I do not
believe this is evidence of alien
contact really good piece
um in the guardian by our friend and
former guest on this program Jason
Stanley
about the so-called culture war that
seeks to ban ideas and ban books and
remove entire subject matter from an
advanced placement black history course
in Florida and say these books shouldn't
be here those books shouldn't be there
and Jason very eloquently explains in
this article titled Banning ideas and
authors is not a culture War it's
fascism
a lot of the important elements of this
and he says it much more eloquently than
I could so I encourage you to read the
article which we're going to link to in
the description to the YouTube video for
this story but I want to build on this
in some way and tell you some of the
ways in which this sort of ideology has
gone very poorly in the past and agree
with Jason that we really can't when we
say this is part of the culture War some
people want to ban books and some don't
this is part of the culture War some
people want to remove the teaching of
certain
um uh lessons from school curricula and
somewhat it's just a cultural War it's
just a disagreement it is critical that
we see it as a form of fascism and when
you look at history when you look at
regimes that have tried or did ban or
burn books silence dissenting voices it
has frequently ended in tragedy or LED
to absolutely horrible circumstances you
have to look at Nazi Germany the burning
of books was a tactic used to suppress
opposition and impose I guess we would
call it like ideological Conformity you
will conform the Nazis knew books could
be powerful tools for challenging their
world worldview so they set out to
destroy those books and materials that
didn't fit with their narrative the
Soviet Union where the government
maintained really strict control over
what people could read and write
descending voices were silenced anyone
who spoke out could be labeled a traitor
or punished extraordinarily severely in
the United States we've seen attempts to
ban books we've seen attempts to censor
ideas throughout history you go to the
McCarthy era we have these more recent
attempts around critical race Theory the
efforts are always about maintaining
power controlling the narrative and
suppressing dissenting ideas and voices
now this is a really
important uh distinction when we talk
about orwellian versus huxleyan okay
often things are called orwellian in
modern society when really modern
American culture is more hoxilian this
book Banning is actually more orwellian
so let me explain this a little bit and
if this is interesting to you it's been
widely written about and explored when
we talk about hoxland we're talking
about Aldous huxili's book Brave New
World
we're talking about a society that has
kind of kept passive and under control
not through force and oppression and the
and the Banning of books but through
pleasure and distraction and
entertainment and that is mostly what we
have when we look I mean Fox News is the
perfect example of hoxland Fox News
mixes opinion and news so you can't tell
which it is they it's the fire Hood uh
fire hose falsehood there's just tons of
stuff being pumped out so you don't even
know what's real and what's not Fox News
and right-wing media match real news
reporting with disinformation to the
point where the average person sometimes
is unclear which is the news and which
is the made up stuff and it encourages
people to be apathetic to be superficial
in their understanding of what's going
on in the world and to Value
entertainment if the news doesn't
entertain me then I'm probably not
watching that's not orwellian most of
what we have in modern American College
culture is actually huxleyan it's you
don't need to do the orwellian stuff
because people are just going to pay
attention to what's entertaining they
can't really tell the difference they're
apathetic anyway okay
when we talk about the book Banning we
are actually talking about something
that is more orwellian where Society is
controlled through oppression and
surveillance and control
and in a Huxley in society information
and ideas are controlled and manipulated
through culture and entertainment and
you can push ideas out or replace them
with things that are more titillating or
whatever the case may be the book
Banning efforts are much more orwellian
because they are a direct attempt to
suppress ideas and information it's
using government censorship in the case
of Florida it's the idea of the state
government wanting to change or control
what is in the curriculum for that black
history course oftentimes it's powerful
interest groups that are controlling or
whatever the case may be it's a much
more direct form of control orwellian
most of American society is huxleyan the
book Banning efforts should be seen as
forms of fascism and they actually are
orwellian
um we'll have more about this discussion
on our Instagram so make sure you are
following us there you can search David
packman show on Instagram
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show well
Donald Trump has his first serious
Challenger I guess serious in the 2024
Republican primary that Challenger is
former South Carolina governor and
Trump's own former ambassador to the
United Nations Nikki Haley Nikki Haley
was expected to announce uh any day
eventually it became clear that she was
going to announce on February 14th which
is of course
what is it is it like National tea day
or something or that Valentine's Day
um Nikki Haley announcing she is indeed
running for president releasing a
three-minute video which I have to tell
you I don't really understand the case
she's making for her own candidacy
highlighting elements of her biography
but appearing to say I'm more or less
like Trump but younger see if you can
figure out what is the case she's making
here and then we're going to talk about
the Outlook we've got new polling and
we'll tell you where Nikki Haley is it's
all getting very interesting take a look
at this
the railroad tracks divided the town by
race
I was the proud daughter of Indian
immigrants okay so playing up racial
diversity starting off with that not
black
not white
I was different it's enlightened
centrism she wasn't black or white she
was Indian that's an interesting
approach
but my mom would always say your job is
not to focus on the differences but the
similarities
and my parents reminded me and my
siblings every day how blessed we were
to live in America
some look at our past as evidence that
America's founding principles are bad
they say the promise of freedom is just
made up
some think our ideas are not just wrong
but racist and Evil
nothing could be further from the truth
I have seen evil
in China they commit genocide
in Iran they murder their own people for
challenging the government
and when a woman tells you about
watching soldiers throw her baby into a
fire
it puts things in perspective
even on our worst day we are blessed to
live in America
I was born and raised in South Carolina
so I have seen the very best of our
country
people here throughout the old tired
political establishment and demanded
accountability for their tax dollars
industry reports called us the Beast of
the southeast
which I loved people came by the
thousands for Fresh Starts moms and dads
held their heads up high children
learned that it was always a great day
in South Carolina it's a great day it's
a great day a great day a great day in
South Carolina
we were strong
we were proud
evil did come
police in South Carolina are looking for
a gunman following a shooting at a
church yeah they when when evil came
they did nothing about gun safety
they're victims we don't know the
severity we turned away from Fear toward
God the values that's true they did
nothing about the guns and they said we
need prayer make our country the freest
and greatest in the world
we must turn in that direction again
Republicans have lost a popular vote in
seven out of the last eight presidential
elections that has to change yeah what
may be better candidates and better
policies would help Joe Biden's record
is
over again it's time for a new
generation of leadership yeah so it
seems to be basically she's Trump but a
new generation meaning younger to
ReDiscover fiscal responsibility secure
our border and strengthen our country
our pride and our purpose
foreign
some people look at America and see
vulnerability
the Socialists left sees an opportunity
to rewrite history by the way the
Socialists on the screen are Nancy
Pelosi
who known for stock trading uh Joe Biden
a center-left Democrat Kamala Harris
very much not a socialist and Bernie who
while describing himself as a Democratic
Socialist actually really runs as a
Social Democrat the this is the best
they can do when it comes to socialists
China and Russia are on the March they
all think we can be bullied kicked
around
should know this about me I don't put up
with bullies and when you kick back it
hurts them more if you're wearing heels
I'm Nikki Haley and I'm running for
president
wow
yeah so Nikki Haley is running her for
president if I understand correctly it
is the standard completely generic
boring old right-wing talking points
combined with she's younger and she's
Indian I mean that that's quite frankly
that's my understanding of what she's
saying here now it will be interesting
to see Trump's reaction as of this
moment Trump has not responded to her uh
challenge of Trump's uh Republican
primary and looking on Truth social here
I don't see that Donald Trump has posted
anything so we'll see the direction that
this goes there is a new morning consult
poll out from this week it has uh Nikki
Haley polling three percent of course
this poll was taken before she announced
her candidacy we'll see if maybe she
could get to four percent or five
percent based on this announcement right
now that tracker has Trump at 4 37
DeSantis at 31 Pence at 7 and Nikki
Haley tied for a heavily contested
fourth place with both Liz Cheney and
Ted Cruz so very very exciting numbers
uh for now for Nikki Haley the primary
is truly starting earlier than ever I
mean it is February we already have
multiple candidates by the way February
not of 24 but of 2023. one of the
Practical questions that comes up
is
do these candidates even really start
campaigning yet Donald Trump really
hasn't other than that one very low
energy event by the way in South
Carolina and putting out some really
strange policy proposals that are not
really policy they're kind of more just
complaints
um we'll see if Nikki Haley starts
campaigning regularly this is you know
if we think of July of next year or even
August uh probably July
um as as the end of the primary we are
talking here about a 17 to 18 month
stretch of primary we already have two
candidates it seems implausible that
they're just going to be aggressively
campaigning starting now but maybe the
fact that it's not just Trump running
anymore is going to force some of that
to get going so Nikki Haley if you
wanted if you're on the Republican side
and you don't like Trump you now have
someone who is actually running actually
running losing very badly to Ron
DeSantis who hasn't even announced but
it is it is at least an official
candidate let let me know whether you
think Haley will make any sort of impact
here Donald Trump is also now reacting
not yet to Nikki Haley saying she's
running
um but reacting to Ron DeSantis and Ron
DeSantis doing better than Trump in some
recent polls and Trump throwing an
absolute and complete tantrum on his
platform truth social truth Central
Donald Trump reacting to a report that
he's obsessed with the santis and spends
time trying to come up with nicknames
for DeSantis including allegedly
meatball Ron I think that's because of
desantis's physical appearance although
I'm not totally sure Donald Trump
posting some triggered messages to truth
Central starting with quote all of the
fake news is reporting that I spend
large amounts of my time coming up with
a good nickname for Ron Des sanctimonius
who is obviously going to give the
presidential thing a shot they are all
one 100 percent wrong I don't even think
about it a very unimportant subject to
me this is the evidence that Trump is
obsessed with Ron DeSantis Trump's
saying I never think about Rhonda santis
or his nicknames to me means he thinks
about Ron DeSantis absolutely all the
time and then weighing in about the
polling some of which really has Trump
doing very poorly compared to Ron
DeSantis Trump saying quote doing great
in poll numbers leading all Republicans
by a lot also leading Biden by a very
wide margin which means that our
weaponized Injustice Department local
DA's and attorney generals oh come on
it's Attorneys General
attorney generals Trump writes will step
up their illegal and unprecedented
attacks in order to disparage me with
false bull
and statements in the hope that I will
be damaged enough to allow a rhino or
Biden to quote slip through the cracks
but be careful the American people get
it and don't like what they are seeing
Maga so this is a very interesting time
for Trump
he knows that the scientist's numbers
are very good for a guy who hasn't
announced anything but if he spends his
time attacking a guy who isn't even
running
it looks very weak Trump wants to be
Alpha and his followers believe him to
be Alpha to some degree as funny as that
is but Trump must realize if he does
spend a lot of time going after a guy
who isn't even actually running against
trump it is kind of pathetic it is
weakening it is disgusting and kind of
kind of lame in a way so he's going to
have to figure out what to do just as
interestingly is that if DeSantis is
going to run against Trump DeSantis has
to figure out when and how to attack
Donald Trump and I want to talk about
that next this is fascinating last week
when Ron DeSantis responded to Trump's
attack on him by saying I don't spend my
time attacking other Republicans
DeSantis took the high road as we
discussed I told you this isn't going to
work for DeSantis and I've expressed
concerns previously that in a national
campaign DeSantis who lacks all Charisma
I mean just completely uncharismatic I
don't know how DeSantis faces off
against Trump and the nicknames and the
attacks in a national campaign
I'm not the only one saying this this is
really interesting there's a New York
Times article published uh two days ago
called desantis's challenge when and how
to counter-attack Trump the article is
by Michael Bender and Maggie Haberman
and in this article they actually
address this issue
he's trying to take the high road but
that is not likely to work and there's a
paragraph that says some deep pocketed
Republican donors have privately
expressed concern about how DeSantis
will perform when forced to directly
engage with an opponent as combative and
unbothered by traditional rules of
decorum as Mr Trump Liam dunovan a
Republican strategist said no Republican
has ever emerged from an exchange with
Donald Trump looking stronger so the
natural tendency is to deflect the tax
and avoid confrontation that's easy to
do maybe wise when Trump's barbs are
confined to truth social the question is
what happens when DeSantis finds himself
on a debate stage opposite Trump and
Republicans vote Republican voters want
to see whether they are getting what
they were promised I think this article
is exactly right and I think that the
Republicans who are bringing this up are
a hundred percent justified in being uh
concerned with this and the article
mentions all of these uh you know
different
um attacks that Trump launched against
challengers in 2016 insinuating that Ted
Cruz's father was linked to the
assassination of John F Kennedy uh
calling Ben Carson pathological making
fun of the appearance of Ted Cruz's wife
and of Rand Paul and so on and so forth
this is exactly right and so while I
believe that at least in theory right
now Ron DeSantis is well positioned for
a run against Trump if he announces and
if he takes the campaign seriously and
he'll he has a shot there's no doubt but
if they emerge as the Front Runners
Trump and DeSantis and if they end up on
stage against each other and DeSantis
does this High Road stuff while Trump
brutally attacks the santus and he will
it doesn't look good for DeSantis I
don't actually believe that Republican
voters are going to be swayed by a guy
who takes the high road I think they
want to see who here brings the sort of
like you know what they what they
wrongly believe to be Alpha energy and
whatever else and uh I don't think the
Santa's taking the high road will work
and DeSantis does need to figure out how
do I attack Trump when do I attack Trump
or the chance that he has at this thing
is going to very quickly evaporate let
me know your thoughts what should
desantis's approach be
um and we will certainly have time to
discuss this further Trump has started
to go after DeSantis in casual
conversations they say describing him as
all sorts of different strange things
based on his physical appearance so
Trump seems to be winding it up and even
though Trump says he's not thinking
about it all of the indications are that
he is Trump's going to be ready this is
you know Trump's not going to be ready
with that health care plan that we were
going to get in August of 2020. I'm not
holding my breath waiting for that
health care plan Trump is going to be
ready for how to attack Ron DeSantis and
DeSantis has to figure out what to do
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
we are seeing an increasingly isolated
and desperate failed former president
Donald Trump descend into a new form of
Madness we heard in an interview
yesterday with his official spokesperson
Liz Harrington that at this point Donald
Trump believes all of his phones are
quote tapped and he is operating as if
that is the case we are going to look at
this clip and understand that it sort of
starts I didn't cut this clip it starts
in this way but what Liz Harrington is
talking about is he just believes that
all of the phones are tapped let's
listen to it and then discuss he's
probably had every phone call ever and
he just assumes so right he assumes
that's the case that's people are
listening in but this man has been spied
on he's been looked at and they have
nothing they've never had anything
because he is so clean I mean he's not
that's why they had such a problem with
him and that's why they still to this
day have such a problem with him because
they're used to being able to have some
sort of Leverage over everybody in
Washington it doesn't matter who they
are there's gonna be something they'll
find it they'll use it against you they
can't do that against President Donald J
Trump that's why they have to make it up
however
even though there's nothing
judges signed off on search warrants
grand juries have been impaneled
multiple criminal investigations but
they have less on Trump than on any
other president he's an open book and
that's what they must be so frustrated
because I was reading this this sham New
York Times article right about Jack
Smith the war prosecutor right they try
to make it serious like oh this is the
type of guy they need to come after
president Trump and he's hired the same
like cast of characters who've gone
after Roger Stone have gone after Steve
Bannon these left-wing hacks they must
be so frustrated because they've spent
their lives on this and yet they still
have really nothing yeah they really
have nothing can anybody prove all of
Trump's phones aren't tapped now let's
talk about this in parts
if Trump's phones are tapped so the
first thing is let's imagine that that's
true let's imagine Trump assumes
correctly that the phones are tapped
even though there's no actually there's
no actual evidence to suggest that that
we're aware of if your phones are tapped
you should be really worried because you
can't just tap people's phones with
willy-nilly law enforcement agencies
need to get a warrant to tap someone's
phone by presenting evidence of probable
cause to a judge and that involves
filing a written application with the
court
justifying the reasons for why you want
to do the phone surveillance and if the
judge determines that the evidence
justifies a wiretap they will issue a
court order authorizing a wiretap so the
idea of trump as squeaky clean
but they've tapped everything
really doesn't make sense because
there's at least the existence of
probable cause that you're not squeaky
clean if your phone is getting tapped at
all going further the idea of trump is
squeaky clean in general is silly
multiple criminal investigations grand
juries subpoenas multiple
um uh impeachments going all the way
back to the Mueller probe that was not
able to clear Donald Trump of
obstruction on and on and on and on and
on but the most interesting part of this
goes back to what we talked about at the
beginning of the show
the right is obsessed with saying the
left is all about saying that they are
victims making themselves into victims
false claims of victimhood and on and on
and on
and yet all the right can do
increasingly is say that they are the
victims and look at all of the things
that Donald Trump has claimed to be the
victim of including through his
spokesperson Liz Harrington a victim of
the Russia hoax a victim of impeachment
number one a victim of impeachment
number two a victim of Judges that won't
let him just do whatever the hell he
wants when it comes to policy treat it
unfairly when it came to adjudicating
the 2020 election it was stolen from him
he was victimized there he was
re-victimized by 63 Court decisions
found against him because those were
also politically biased his family has
been victimized even though the reason
this family is being made fun of is Don
and Eric particularly are just pathetic
jokes in terms of the public statement
that they but he's the greatest victim
they know no bottom to this and it's
going to continue being a theme in the
2024 campaign pain and if he ends up
dropping out before the primaries which
is increasingly a topic of discussion it
will be because he's the victim of
something it's not going to be hey you
know what the uh electorate decided
they're going a different direction they
don't want me and I respect that
what Trump would never say that it will
be the fake news media conspiring with
rhinos and the Republican establishment
and the judicial system which has been
weaponized they all made me a victim
and they pushed me out of the campaign
or whatever that's the way it's going to
be as Trump descends further into
madness what exactly happened to Bill
Maher is a question that many of you
have been writing to me and asking
because he has made some increasingly
strange comments lately that don't
really seem to fit with the perception
of Bill Maher but I actually am going to
show you today
um a transcript from an interview I
remember watching that Bill Maher did 18
years ago and I am going to argue that
Bill Maher hasn't really changed he's
just sort of shifted his focus and
shifted what he talks about but it's the
same Bill Maher today that it was in the
past so first and foremost Bill Maher
recently appeared uh with Fran Lebowitz
on his podcast it was an interesting
conversation but I disagree with a lot
of things that Bill Maher is saying
increasingly doesn't mean I I disagree
with him on everything but increasingly
he's saying things that don't really
make a lot of sense here he was sort of
glamorizing Ron DeSantis take a listen
to this I mean compared to Trump he
doesn't have a giant ass he has hair you
know he's got uh I mean compared to
Trump he has policies which Trump
doesn't have and the policies are really
horrible well he does a lot of
performative art yes some of it is is a
reaction to policies that were insane to
begin with like the don't say gay sure
Ron DeSantis does some performative
stuff but it's because the left forced
him to no first of all it doesn't say
that and it doesn't say don't say gay
um parents were not look he does a lot
of stupid things I agree he campaigned
for election deniers that's a big red
flag with me yeah but parents were not
unreasonably concerned that schools had
become a place where kids were being
exposed to ideas about gender and race
that were completely inappropriate for
someone three years old you're making my
case for me they may have been however I
don't think I think he does these things
to distract from his real policies which
are
let's stop Social Security cut Medicare
you know those are the real things look
and especially in Florida where 90 of
the people already on Social Security
right you're saying he's for maybe maybe
the party is he is too I mean he is too
I mean I'm less worried about him so you
know kind of glamorizing Rhonda santis
and sure he does some crazy stuff but a
lot of it is because he's being forced
into doing it by the woke left or
whatever the case may be and then he
goes into uh the topic of covid and
covid rules all turned out to be stupid
maybe this maybe this makes people
understand why some of us who called out
a lot of the uh nonsense with how we
handled covid we're so skeptical because
we've done stupid Health theater for a
long time it's not new we've handled
almost every Health crisis badly not all
of them
um and you know I found it just arrogant
to have such a bad record in the past
with health matters now some of what
Bill Maher is saying here isn't wrong
the U.S has a bad record of handling
Health emergencies there was a lot of
uncertainty in communication problems
and all of these different things the
problem is that Bill Maher presents it
all in a way that opens the door to the
science deniers and the um anti-vaxxers
and all of it and he is being used in
that way just tell me just do what we
say when have we ever been wrong and
then it's like oh okay uh we're washing
the mail and they told us you know like
we're any kind of mask they're all good
just some bandana put a diaper on your
head it doesn't matter everything's fine
and I remember
um don't touch your face was about a big
hit song for about a year don't touch
your face I'm not up on which covet
rules you were opposed to
they all turned out to be stupid not all
which ones it was not on the mail no oh
no that item they just found they just
did a study the masks unless they were
n95 and maybe not even them useless
um you know I I stopped wearing a
mascara you didn't have to wear it
anymore and you all remember it's all
it's all degrees and it's well no The
Masks are increasingly less effective
the lower quality they are and we have
studies and we know that but it's
exactly this type of black and white
thinking offhanded flippant black and
white thinking that opens the door to
people who believe anything to say oh I
was right I was right but
but that's just but I the vaccines look
I'm glad there were the vaccines yes I'm
glad there were vaccines I don't don't
plea you know what it's if that's your
choice great uh there are some vaccines
I would love to have and might need and
would fight you for but if I don't but I
should be able to make my own medical
decisions you are not a nurse okay
you're not in the hospital you know I
think it depends who you are you know uh
right well you're saying they would have
to get the best yes well I mean okay but
here's something stupid we did that
other countries didn't do countries I
think you would respect by the way
countries you're going to I'm going to
do your plugs what a great segue but
like you're a much more recognized
natural immunity if you're a nurse and
you had it naturally at the beginning
which a lot of nurses did then it was
stupid and pointless and yeah you know
it wasn't really stupid and pointless
because if you had it at the beginning
by the time that the vaccines were out
we started to see an evolution to
different variants and as we know four
or five months after that the vaccine's
effectiveness when it came to preventing
infection was dramatically lower so your
immunity uh 15 months later to a variant
that is not even actually the variant
that's out there anymore isn't going to
be particularly useful so anyway the
point here is I don't I'm not saying
Bill Maher's a bad guy and I'm not
saying he's wrong about everything but
he has had this streak particularly on
medical stuff for a very long time let
me present to you an exhibit okay I
remember watching this interview and I
went and searched for a clip I couldn't
find a clip but I found a transcript 18
years ago in 2005 Bill Maher was
interviewed by Larry King
and he claims that the flu shot makes
Alzheimer's more likely and says aspirin
is bad now you might say David that's
Bill Maher would never say that let's
put up the transcript on the screen Bill
Maher says well I hate to tell you Larry
but if you have a flu shot for more than
five years in a row there's 10 times the
likelihood that you'll get Alzheimer's
disease I would stop getting your and
King says what did you say and Mara says
that went better than in rehearsal but
it was still good absolutely no the
defense against this against disease is
to have a strong immune system a flu
shot compromises your immune system now
this has been studied the flu shot
reduces the risk for for Alzheimer's
among those aged 65 plus this has been
studied this it's it's not even
something Bill Maher brought up that
hadn't been studying said it has been
studied we know that that is not true
okay this was Bill Maher 18 years ago
and then Larry King says so you don't
take any Western medicine don't take an
aspirin and Bill Maher says never an
aspirin no thousands of people die from
aspirin every year
and King says how do you treat illness
and Bill Maher says I promise you if you
get a headache the reason for the
headache is not aspirin deficiency which
I remember being 20 and watching this
and saying Bill Maher can't be this
stupid right imagine applying that idea
listen the reason you have cancer is not
a chemo deficiency so why would you give
someone chemo well because that's not
how medication Works medication is not
about giving you something you were
deficient in medications work in a lot
of different ways from monoclonal
antibodies to uh antibiotics so it's
it's not about I lack aspirin my
headache is caused by a lack of aspirin
so I will cure the headache by taking
aspirin the idea that that's Bill Marsh
train of thought is very disturbing
because it's so stupid and then um Bill
Larry King says no of course not Bill
Maher says right so you're taking and
King says something to take the pain
away why is that bad and Bill Maher says
but why don't you find out the real root
of that pain and Larry King says well
while you're finding take the aspirin
which is actually a pretty funny line
from Larry King so the point here is
Bill Mars had this streak for a very
long time time it's not actually new
covid made it more of a focus for him
and I think that's where we are today
I have a voicemail number you can call
anytime 2192 David P here is a caller
who is again confused about whether or
not I am a socialist listen to this
did you just misspeak I thought I just
heard you say that you are a Social
Democrat right don't you mean to say you
are a Democratic Socialist no would that
be more accurate no no I didn't misspeak
sir I am not a Democratic Socialist
Democratic socialism is a form of
Socialism
I am a Social Democrat which is a
well-regulated form of capitalism I did
not misspeak I am not a socialist some
on the right and even some on the left
think I am a socialist but I'm not
I'm not criticizing socialism in this
segment I'm just saying I'm not
socialist it's sort of like if you say
David didn't you say you were black and
I would go no I didn't say I was black
I'm not black oh so you don't like black
people no I'm not saying that I'm just
saying I happen not to be black that's
all I'm saying okay I'm not a socialist
please
um okay we have a great bonus show for
you today we are going to talk about the
apoplectic reaction to Rihanna's Super
Bowl performance we are going to talk
about lawmakers or as Donald Trump once
called them La markers focusing in on
chat GPT in the uh in this growing
popularity for the tool and we are going
to talk about a bill from Bernie Sanders
to boost Social Security benefits not
cut but rather boost all of those
stories and more are on the bonus show
thank your lucky stars every day you're
not Dave Pacman well I get to host the
bonus show Alex so that's an exciting
thing sign up at joinpakman.com I will
see you then